what are all positive values of P such
that the series converges so let's see
we have the sum from N equals 1 to
infinity of negative 1 to the n plus 1
times P over 6 to the N so there's a
couple of things that might jump out at
you this negative 1 to the n plus 1 as n
goes from 1 to 2 to 3 this is just going
to alternate between positive 1 negative
1 positive 1 negative 1 so we're going
to have alternating signs so that might
be a little bit of a clue of what's
going on and actually let's just write
it out this is going to be see what N
equals 1 this is going to be to the
second power so it's going to be
positive 1 10 so it's going to be P over
6 and then when n is 2 this is going to
be to the third power so it's going to
be minus P over 6 squared then plus P
over 6 to the third power and I could
even write to the first power right over
here then minus P over 6 to the fourth
power and we're going to just keep going
plus/minus on and on and on and on
forever so this is clearly this is a
classic alternating series right over
here and so we can actually apply our
alternating series test and our
alternating series test tells us that if
this part of our expression the part
that is not alternating in sign I guess
you could say if this part of the
expression is monotonically decreasing
monotonic alee monotonically decreasing
which is just a fancy way of saying that
each successive term is less than the
term before it and if we also know that
the limit of this as n approaches
infinity that also has to be equal to 0
so the limit as n approaches infinity of
P over 6 to the nth power also has to be
equal to 0
so under what conditions is that going
to be true well to meet either one of
those conditions P over 6 has to be less
than 1 if P over 6 was equal to 1 for
example P was 6 well then we wouldn't be
monotonically decreasing every term here
would just be 1 it would be 1 to the 1 1
squared on and on and on and if P is
greater than 6
well then every time we multiply by
P over six again we would get a larger
number over and over again and the limit
for sure would not be equal to zero so
we could say P over six needs to be less
than one and so multiply both sides by
six and you get P it needs to be less
than six and they told us for what are
what are all the positive positive
values of P so we also know that P has
to be greater than zero so P is greater
than zero and less than six which is
that choice right over here and once
again we're not going to say less than
or equal to six because if P was equal
to six this term is going to be one to
the N and so we're just going to have
this would be 1 this would be 1 would be
1 minus 1 plus 1 and on and on and on
forever so definitely like that first
choice